[Music]
it's Justin Timberlake set to pay
tribute to a music legend during his
Super Bowl halftime show
Kevin Bridgers in Minneapolis where JT
is in his final prep so whatcha know keV
Nancy there is down speculation that
Justin will honor Prince during his
halftime performance the latest clue JT
gave us a listen to his new album inside
Prince's famous estate
[Applause]
I've mentioned myself I still can't
believe I'm have Paisley Park with
Sunday's countdown on Justin was looking
relaxed humbled and clearly honored to
throw the first non Prince party ever
allowed inside the late icons estate
kissing wife Jessica Biel on the dance
floor during the American Express album
listening event many are now wondering
if Justin will pay tribute to the purple
one on the Pepsi halftime stage a man is
a huge influence on me that influence
has been an undeniable presence
throughout Justin's biggest hits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but in his new video for man of the
woods Jessica takes the lead as his
biggest influence wearing a stunning
backless white dress is Justin lifts her
up on the dance floor man of the woods
is the meaning of their nearly
three-year old son Silas's name now into
Justin's Super Bowl fashion here's a
first look at the custom Stella
McCartney design sketches you'll rock
during the big game the in Samba will
consist of a dark fringe jacket over an
organic cotton shirt you'll also wear
camo trousers made of repurposed wool
speaking of Super Bowl style it's hard
not to think about Justin and this
infamous wardrobe malfunction from his
last halftime show what are you
expecting from Justin Timberlake I still
think Janet Jackson's gonna make a
surprise appearance he's wearing
breakaway pants and she's just pulling
them off
you
[Music]